[Music]
a morning training session is a chance
for the players at Alpha United juniors
to enjoy their football free of abuse
but in matches the racism endured can
seem constant
well you know I know we're playing away
um a predominantly white area then
sometimes it can get a bit nasty and if
I like winning good if like comfortably
winning then you know I'll get it they
take the anger out
um but sometimes you know it can be a
bit racist at the top of the game
Premier League players have been taking
the knee again recently so the important
message that there is no room for racism
but for this Grassroots team in Bradford
those powerful messages aren't producing
the change desired with more protection
for victims of racism we call we're
striving iffy at that point and say look
we're gonna go off they told us to
continue we said look we don't want to
continue because of what is going on we
said we'll report the light channels we
went off and then there was a lot of
slurs bad language towards our kids as
well as me as a coach
this is just one Grassroots Club out of
thousands The Season's only just begun
and the abuse has begun the racism being
experienced by these kids at games is a
trauma that they feel the authorities
are just not acting on you seem to have
lost confidence in the system yeah 100 I
think is a lack of confidence after
doing it for many years after over the
last 10 years and nothing gets done you
don't have no trust in the system and
you just think what is the point of
requiring anything anymore to the league
or the fa discrimination monitors kick
it out rely on those reports with 74
receives of racial or religious abuse in
the Grassroots game in the 2019-20
season there were still 66 cases the
next season despite lockdowns and 109
cases were investigated last season
almost 70 percent of all forms of
discrimination reporting it's about
having people in place who understand
the nature of discrimination and can
deal with it appropriately and properly
but it needs all parts parties to come
to the table and take this issue
seriously and deal with it and deal with
the perpetrators
Alpha United Juniors winners of a
queen's award for voluntary service want
assurances their County fa will
rigorously act against abusers despite
West riding officials telling us that
they take all forms of discrimination
seriously it can make you drop your head
sometimes but you just need to keep
strong and you know it can really hurt
you sometimes in you might feel like
well like what have I done I'm just
playing football doing what I love but
it's just people take the anger out on
you and you just got you just have to
keep your head up
it's a frustration that troublingly
resonates across Grassroots football Rob
Harris Sky News Bradford
and while the West riding fa was unable
to provide a specific response to the
concerns of alpha United Juniors they
have sent the following response at West
riding fa we treat all allegations of
discrimination with the utmost
importance as we strive to have a game
free from discrimination we would urge
that anyone that's a victim of
discrimination should contact us so that
we can investigate fully